I mean you kind of broke the internet
with your emotional breakup on the two
we still talking about that midnight
money another baby by now I was gonna
say do you have another man or what's
going on the man is Will Smith and I'm
just hanging out with him
it felt horrible but at the same time it
felt great because of the support that
we got we got insane support and I mean
it's like there wasn't a single bad
comment that I saw that like bummed any
of us how everyone was on our team
they got lies to the back they got my
back it's there's a happy ending to sad
event I know you guys are so close
friends I'm young is there any hope out
there that you guys might get back
together
no no idea I I try not to think about it
we both have a lot of work to do for
ourselves and then if something happens
happens later than it happens happily
ever after or not lie sicko she says her
and David's working relationship will
continue the blog squad is untouchable
that's my boy David Oberg so you know no
he has I mean he's an insane director so
I'm just excited to see maybe you'll see
some projects y'all know I'm not crying
I'm just a good actor they're coming up
in the world in so many ways fill you
one feels good I'm sorry I just touched
my rentals right now oh you're feeling
100 any I'm feeling good this took five
hours to get ready and it was worth it
birthday you look stunned me I tried
what an amazing year for you I mean what
has been the biggest highlight for you
because you've been hanging out with
some pretty major men uh-huh
seriously no but he's he's a blessing to
have you it's like so generous of his
energy and so like to be able to learn
from him and be able to win an award for
being like an actress tonight and then
to be learning from my favorite actor
like that's that's all a girl freaking
can dream of but I didn't even dream of
this I couldn't have dreamt of some life
as great as this so thank you I'm
blessed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]